my question is for kevin anthony and
sebastian
captain america is now gone that's a
huge impact on the mcu
so what is that like and since you are
both now some of the older surviving
avengers
what responsibility do you feel leading
future heroes
um well i think
it was it was a end game was a
monumental
uh shift of the superhero universe
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today i got to attend the marvel
studios
and disney press conference virtually
for the falcon and the winter soldier
and during this press conference i got
to speak to kevin feige
sebastian stan anthony mackey corey
skoglin who directed the show
and malcolm spellman the head writer of
the show and the beginning clip you saw
is me getting to ask a question to kevin
feige
anthony mackie who of course plays
falcon and sebastian stan who of course
plays the winter soldier i'll be doing
an
entire breakdown of the whole press
conference for the falcon and the winter
soldier tomorrow but in the meantime
i wanted to tell you what they had to
say to me when i asked them a question
so again my question was as follows in
the clip my question
is for kevin anthony and sebastian
captain america is now gone that's a
huge impact on the mcu
so what is that like and since you are
both now some of the older surviving
avengers
what responsibility do you feel leading
future heroes
then anthony mackie answered me first
then sebastian stan answered and then
kevin feige himself answered as well
now unfortunately i was asked not to
share any more footage than i just
shared but i can tell you exactly what
they said
anthony mackie said that avengers
in-game was a monumental shift
of the superhero universe he continued
to say the scope of that movie
the idea of that film is something
larger than i think
anyone imagined our goal and we've
talked about this
i'll speak for sebastian was not to mess
it up
we didn't want to be the first crappy
marvel
project and as he said this him myself
and pretty much everybody else burst
into laughter
and i can personally assure you that
this show does not
suck but he went on to say our job was
to take the
torch and not make a bad show i'm very
happy to say that steve rogers will be
proud that our show
does not suck he continued to say that i
say
all that to say our show does not suck
and we are not the first
crappy marvel project so the next show
has a problem
because if it's bad they're gonna be the
first crappy marvel project in like
20 years from there everybody laughed
and then sebastian stan chimed in and
said what are you saying about loki in
which anthony replied
i don't know i don't know i'm just
saying i'm just saying and then
sebastian stan
actually addressed my question as well
after director kari skoglyn encouraged
him to answer by saying come on
sebastian get yourself in trouble
then anthony mackie actually commented
on my captain america winter soldier
shirt
saying come on look at that shirt look
at that shirt
then sebastian stan answered my question
by saying that question that you just
asked is very much built into the arc
of both of these characters where they
are at at the top of the show you know
and actually answering that question and
exploring that question
is very much their journey throughout
the show who am i now
what do i have to contribute that guy
did this and this
so what is gonna be my legacy if
i even want that so there's all these
pieces to it that kind of are
interesting rather than just coming out
of the gate and saying you know
i have all the answers marvel studios
president kevin feige then stepped in
adding well i will just end and say that
we never would have attempted this or
tried this or have been as excited to
bring the series to disney plus
if we didn't have unbelievable actors
like anthony mackie and sebastian stan
playing these characters and being able
to bring them to life and know that we
can pile six hours on them
and it'll work and they could go further
and obviously with malcolm
and kari bringing them to life in ways
that are above and beyond and not on
this call
nate moore and zoe naglehout who brought
in malcolm and kari who were there every
single day
all making what the show is which is as
anthony says
the show that doesn't suck and i was
actually the last question of the entire
press conference
so after this it was the end now i also
did interview the director kari skoglyn
one on one and that will be posting
hopefully tomorrow
and i actually can show the footage for
that so that's pretty exciting because
she had a lot of good things to say
about the show some very interesting
things to say that i think a lot of
people are going to enjoy
and yes i did ask her about mephisto but
one thing i can tell you about the
falcon and the winter soldier is what
anthony mackie said it does not suck in
fact it is far from sucking it's an
amazing show
i loved one division but this is a
straightforward marvel show
and i like it a little bit more so stay
on the lookout for my entire press
conference breakdown that should be up
tomorrow and my interview with director
kari skoglund that should be up tomorrow
or the next day as well
just want to say thank you to everybody
who has supported me up to this point to
get me here to where i can actually talk
to the people at marvel
it's a dream come true and i owe it all
to you i hope i can bring you more
awesome content like this where i
actually talk with everybody at marvel
and from the bottom
of my heart woof